If you don't know, Journey to the Microcosmos
has its own Microcosmos Microscope.
A microscope we designed specifically for
people who are new to the hobby of Microscopy.
Who maybe want to discover their
very first tardigrade.
It's a really wonderful moment, I had mine
about two and a half years ago.
And with the Microcosmos Microscope you
are able to attach your phone to it
So you can take pictures and video
of the things that you discover.
When I first wanted to try out microscopy,
I found the step of finding the right
microscope to start with very intimidating,
so we're just trying to make that easier
for everybody.
You can find it and a bunch of other stuff like
great shirts and socks to celebrate
the microscopic world around us at
microcosmos.store.
If you need to nominate an ambassador
to represent the microcosmos,
you have to go with the tardigrade.
They are weird, adorable, and very hardy,–
a combination of traits that has made them
many people’s first entry point into the
microscopic world.
And no matter how much time you spend with them,
tardigrades will find new ways to surprise you.
In fact, when we’ve looked back on our journey
through the microcosmos and our encounters
with tardigrades, we’ve noticed that many
of those strange sightings involve something
that doesn’t immediately come to mind with
tardigrades:
sex.
So today, we want to thread together these
tales of tardigrade mating, and not just because
it’s fun, but also because there’s a lot
to learn from understanding how tardigrades
make more of themselves.
Let’s start with one of our early videos
about tardigrades, where we were introduced
a pregnant water bear whose eggs were beginning
to develop even as her body remained still,
and whose fate we’ll get to see play out
later in this compilation.
We don’t know about you, but here on the
Microcosmos team, we find it hard not to smile
as we watch tardigrades with their cute, pitch-black
eyes and little feet ambling across the smooth
glass surface of the microscope slide.
Moss piglets, water bears—whatever you call
them, they’re fascinating to watch, and
even more fascinating to try and understand.
They are a puzzle, and we humans are the puzzler.
And so we figured, sure, we’ve already focused
on tardigrades in a previous episode.
But we cannot possibly leave it there.
After all, like the microscopic world around
them, tardigrades always have more to show us.
Our water bears are collected from ponds and
growing moss, environments that give them
the water and food they need to thrive.
And so, behind the scenes, we like to give
them a bit of attention, making sure that
they are well fed and comfortable in their
slides.
After all, a drop of water is barely anything
to us, but to a tardigrade, a thing so tiny
and so good at surviving, that drop can be
everything.
Tardigrades of course live their lives, absent
of any kind of intention to teach us anything.
They don’t even know we’re here.
But watching is a form of interaction, and
one that reveals the interface between the
micro, the macro, and even the cosmic.
So let’s start with a part of the tardigrade
body whose weirdness we haven’t had the
chance to fully appreciate here yet: their
mouths.
The opening of the tardigrade mouth is a distinct
ring, giving way to a tube that connects to
the pharyngeal bulb, which helps the tardigrade
suction out the juicy contents of its meal.
But to get to the juice, the tardigrade first
needs to pierce its target, relying on a pair
of stylets that poke out of the mouth ring
when it comes time to feed.
When the tardigrade molts, they shed their
stylets and replace them with a new pair.
Tardigrades are omnivorous, they’re open
to eating bacteria, plants, and animals.
For some species, their meal might even be
another tardigrade.
But for the species here, our samples contain
plenty of algae and plant matter for them
to dine on, collected from the same watery
and earthy worlds as the tardigrades these
bits of organic matter keep them well fed
like a built-in buffet.
But there are other times where bearing witness
to the microcosmos takes a little more adaptation
on our part.
Recently, we found a water bear with its half-shed
cuticle filled with eggs, still attached to
its body in what amounts to parenting in the
microcosmos.
As you might imagine, we were more than a
little curious to watch these eggs develop.
But if you keep a slide on a microscope for
too long, the water will evaporate, taking
with it the moisture the tardigrade needs
to exist outside of its dessicated, dormant state.
So we kept these slides in humidity chambers
and took extra care to make sure the coverslip
wouldn’t crush the developing tardigrades.
And then…we watched.
The tardigrade though was still.
This video is from our sixth day of observation,
the only sign of life being the absence of
decomposition.
Three days later, we can see the eggs are
developing, and there are even little tardigrade
heads appearing.
The mother still seems the same, attached
to her eggs and seemingly still alive despite
her complete stillness.
When it comes time to hatch, the embryos
will use their stylets and pharyngeal pump
to make their way out, sucking in water to
increase the pressure on the egg from the
inside until the shell breaks.
But…we’re still waiting for that day to
come with this tardigrade brood.
Embryonic development in tardigrade can last
from 5 days to more than 100, varying by species
and dependent on environmental factors like
temperature.
The thing with biology, no matter what scale
of creature you’re looking at, is that you’re
always on their schedule, not the other way
around.
Food and birth probably seem a bit domestic
compared to some of the more recent tardigradian
exploits you may have heard about.
Earlier in 2019, Israel sent a spacecraft
called Beresheet to the moon, taking with
it, among many things, a digital archive of
almost the entirety of English Wikipedia and
also thousands of tardigrades, dried out in
their ball-like tun form and ready for lift off.
Seconds before Beresheet was supposed to land,
however, it lost contact with Mission control
and crashed instead, leaving one very obvious
question: what will happen to those thousands
of tardigrades, potentially spilled across
the surface of the moon.
Our seeming penchant for sending tardigrades
into space has taught us that they’re able
to tolerate vacuums.
Without liquid water, of course, the tardigrades
will remain in their dormant state.
Maybe if someone is able to return to that
crash site decades from now, they might manage
to find tardigrades that survived that crash,
and there’s a chance that with a little
water, they could come back to life.
We’re still working to understand all of
the tricks of tardigrade survival, how does
it play out in their DNA and proteins, and
why some tardigrade species seem to be better
than others.
This is part of the fun of tardigrades and
our collective fascination with them.
We’re all learning together here on planet
earth, like a giant science classroom, asking
important questions like, “Is that round
thing the mouth?” and “What does happen
when you put a tardigrade on the moon?”
Maybe this is our 21st century remix of Apollo,
a conversation between microcosmos and good
old-fashioned cosmos.
Science is ultimately a mix of deliberate
and accidental questions, taking on many forms
to suit our available tools.
Sometimes science is a detailed study, and
sometimes it’s a crash landing.
It can be a collector of microbes and a master
of microscopes, carefully tending to samples
to meet the needs of their invisible residents.
And sometimes it’s you, watching along,
making your own observations, maybe even thinking
of new questions that no one has ever thought
to ask before.
In our next video, we’re jumping straight
to the point.
This is a video about tardigrade sex, featuring,
you know, tardigrades having sex.
And the process is about as perplexing to watch
as you might imagine tardigrade mating would be.
Welcome to season two of Journey to the Microcosmos,
and we are starting things off with a pun
very much intended--a bang.
Or more accurately, a multitude of bangs.
And we should warn you, it gets weird: there's
poop!
There's molted skin!
There's the inexhaustible spirit of the tardigrade
in flagrante!
So, how did we get here?
Well, sex, obviously, if we're talking in
the grand biological scheme of things.
It is for some, an evolutionarily advantageous
way of making offspring.
But we're talking about tardigrade sex right
now in part because of a pregnant water bear
that we started tracking in an episode last
season.
Even though the mother-to-be was completely
motionless, we were able to see the heads
of baby tardigrades forming in the eggs, and
we were excited to record and share the moment
of all those moss piglets hatching.
Unfortunately, nature had different plans,
and we'll talk about that more in our next episode.
But James, our master of microbes, has been
hard at work documenting the lives of the
tardigrades in his care.
And that means, not only have we been able
to find more tardigrades hatching, we've seen
some particularly vivid demonstrations of
the steps that came before.
These hardy animals can reproduce asexually
via parthenogenesis, but our recent samples
have been full of frisky water bears, and
that is what we are going to focus on today.
Sure, tardigrades contain an immense capacity
for survival that astounds and boggles the
mind, and it is a joy and a privilege to share
the biology and visual wonders of their lives
alongside all of the other tiny organisms
we talk about.
But sometimes, what the job asks for, maybe
even demands, is that we film nature
as it occurs.
This is not what James expected when he ventured
out to a river to collect some mud, even when
it turned out that he had hit a microbial
jackpot and counted at least 15 tardigrades
on the first slide he prepared from the sample.
But as he continued to watch, he saw these
two smaller tardigrades, both mysteriously
drawn to the underbelly of a larger one.
They seemed to be trying to reach into the
belly with their piercing mouths, but the
why's and the how's and the who's were all
unclear.
Their goal was mysterious.
And besides, tardigrades rarely demonstrate
such a focused interest on much of anything.
But twenty minutes later, those two jabbers
were still at it.
Their determination became much more understandable
when the eggs inside the bigger tardigrade
become visible, marking her as a female holding
a number of unfertilized eggs, and marking
the smaller tardigrades as males vying to
do the fertilization in a microscopic love
triangle (or as we call it at the Microcosmos
headquarters, a "ménage à trois-digrade").
Was that too much?
Who knows?
So just how focused are these male tardigrades?
Well, remember that time we watched a solitary
tardigrade poop?
What a nice, surprisingly cute and relaxing
clip that was.
Well, now, let's watch a large female tardigrade
defecate with apparently no care at all for
her suitors, and watch those two continue
poking the water bear anyway, undaunted by
the cloud of poop around them.
But even tardigrades surrender eventually,
and after thirty minutes of this poking and prodding,
one of the males made a graceful exit,
perhaps having lost out on the mating battle.
With the path clear, the remaining male got
a good hold onto the female's cuticle, sticking
with her for a whole hour in their joint endeavor
to fertilize her eggs.
This couple was not the only one we observed
in action.
In fact, this sample was full of tardigrades
mating.
And the behavior we observed was consistent,
which is important scientifically.
Given the collective fascination with tardigrades,
it might surprise you to learn that their
sex lives have not been well-documented.
Perhaps the most thorough study we were able
to find is a 2016 paper that was conducted
by scientists at the Senckenberg Museum of
Natural History in Görlitz, Germany.
It was published in the Zoological Journal
of the Linnean Society, and their work chronicles
the mating behavior of Isohypsibius dastychi, a
different species from the one we are observing here.
But their work was still a helpful basis from
which to understand the various oddities and
necessities of water bear sex.
The adulthood of tardigrades is often defined
by the number of molts it takes for them to
reach sexual maturity.
For example, the female I. dastychi develops
eggs during her third molt.
But at this stage, the female doesn't shed
off their molted outside, called the exuvia.
They molt their cuticle...but then they stay
in it...like wearing your shed skin like a
coat, and why not?
They stay in there, along with their eggs.
When male tardigrades were added to the mix,
they made a beeline for these egg-bearing females.
In the exact technical terms used by the scientists
in the paper, the process starts with the
male "bringing his cloaca close the mouth
opening in the exuvia."
And thus begins a process of "mutual stimulation,"
the female uses her stylets and sucking pharynx
to prod at the male's abdomen as part of a
mating process that will take, similar to
our tardigrades, about an hour.
It all ends, of course, with ejaculation,
but how that fertilization occurs can vary.
In some species, sperm might enter through
an opening in the exuvia.
In others, the male might use their stylets
to poke holes in the shed cuticle that they
then deposit their sperm into.
One species has been seen using both of those
methods.
The observations that have been documented
are that challenging combination of rare and
different, where it's not clear how everything
fits together.
And in cases like the species we're looking
at right now, that means the mechanisms actually
remain unclear.
The sexual habits of this species are undocumented,
this is science, right here, you’re watching it.
As for when and how the sperm is deposited,
either we weren’t able to film the exact
right moment, or it happened so subtly that
we missed it.
In short, it’s different for different species,
and it is not well studied and even though
we had a slide full of frisky tardigrades,
it was still a challenge to observe.
Sometimes, here at Journey to the Microcosmos,
we end our episodes talking about how observing
the microcosmos gives us new and better perspectives
on the whole rest of the world.
But sometimes, we’re just excited to have
the opportunity to see something so few people
have seen, and that’s just interesting…
because it is.
And hopefully this video will be part of a hopefully
ongoing tradition to record tardigrade mating.
And next week, we’re going to be back with
the fruits of their labor, to show you the
highs and the lows of tardigrade birth.
We’re going to be returning to the fates of the
tardigrades in those first two videos in a bit.
But before we do that, we wanted to digress
a little.
We ended that last video with the hope that
we would be part of a developing tradition
of recorded tardigrade mating, a necessary
step in developing our understanding of how
tardigrades reproduce.
Well, a few years later, we returned to the
tardigrade to learn more about a much more
established tradition—
that is the tradition of people coming up
with strange theories about tardigrade sperm.
This is not an organism.
At least, it’s not yet anyway.
What we are looking at are a lot of zoospores
packed together, getting ready to be released
so that they can find the right place to grow
into themselves.
And this?
Well, this is a male tardigrade filled from
head to many toes with sperm.
Just chock full of it.
We did not start this channel with the intent
of becoming so familiar with tardigrade mating
habits, but tardigrades are easy to find,
and their mating habits are straightforward
enough to track, so we keep getting drawn
back into the details and
the drama of tardigrade reproduction.
In the past, we’ve talked about the particulars
of their mating habits.
And today, we’re going to use this tardigrade
as a convenient starting point to talk about
the history of our understanding of sperm.
Because as absurd as it might seem to be looking
at tardigrade sperm, the theories people have
had about sperm are much weirder.
Humans have been theorizing about the contents
of seminal fluid long before the invention
of the microscope.
We did not, as a species, need to work out
all of the scientific mechanisms underlying
sexual reproduction to make babies.
But the observation of children who carried
traits from their parents naturally raised
questions about how those traits were passed
on.
And those questions inevitably led to some
hypotheses.
And look, not all hypotheses need to be good.
In fact, many of them are terrible.
It’s just that when you’re trying to understand
the world, you need to start somewhere, and
as long as you’re willing to work with your
ideas and challenge them, then hopefully some
day, you go from somewhere, to somewhere better.
Some of these early ideas about sperm weren’t
just bad though, they were, maybe as we should
expect, a little self-serving to the male
ego.
Masturbatory, even, you could say.
Like the theory now known as spermism, advocated
for by one Pythagorus, yes, that Pythagorus.
According to spermism, the information driving
heredity came entirely through the semen.
Whether that was the color of someone’s
hair or their height or whatever other trait—
all of that came through the father, and the
father’s father, and so on.
The mother’s role was just to provide nourishment
to the sperm as it developed and manifested those traits.
It’s easy enough to find flaws with this
idea.
After all, our observed reality, which Pythagorus
just chose to ignore, shows us that traits
pass from mother and father alike.
But this would not be the last theory to overestimate
the sperm.
Even with the advance of scientific tools
over the ages, there was plenty to get wrong.
One of those key scientific tools was, of
course, the microscope, which allowed scientists
to observe the cells within semen for the
first time.
But just because microscopists could see sperm
now, that did not mean they could make out
the details.
And this invited speculation, including the
idea that we are essentially developed from
a much smaller version of ourselves.
This theory was called preformationism.
At the end of the 17th century, the Dutch
scientist Nicolaas Hartsoeker sketched out
his spermist vision of preformationism:
inside the head of the sperm cell, he speculated,
was a very, very, very small human--
later called a homunculus--
just waiting for a womb to grow in.
And look, we have the advantage of centuries
of advancements to know that the homunculus
was wrong.
But maybe take a moment to think about how
weird that would be if it were right.
Look at this tardigrade, full of sperm.
And then just imagine if we zoomed in further
on those sperm cells, and we could see little
tiny tardigrades inside of them.
And then, if we could zoom in even more on
those tinier tardigrades, we’d see even
more tinier tardigrades inside of them, and
so on and so on.
Now, to be clear, that is not what tardigrade
sperm looks like.
Their sperm is made up of a slightly globular
head connected to a flagellum.
But as wrong as both spermism and tiny people
inside of sperm turned out to be, they’re
not that far off the mark if you think about
the zoospores we showed at the beginning of
the episode.
They are a tool of asexual reproduction in
a lot of different organisms, including algae,
fungi, and bacteria.
They all use zoospores in different ways.
And because we don’t know exactly what organism
these zoospores come from, there are specific
details of their lives we just don’t know.
But take, for example, the Phytophthora, a
group of oomycetes most notorious for their
role in the 19th century potato blight that
led to the Great Famine in Ireland.
Phytophthora can reproduce sexually, but they
mostly rely on making asexual zoospores, which
pack together in a biological enclosure called
the sporangia until the conditions are right
for their release.
And when they emerge from the sporangia, the
zoospores start swimming, using their flagella
and chemical sensors to find the ideal place
to settle and germinate.
All of the hereditary information in those
zoospores came from one parent, fashioning
an organism that resembles the infant form
of that parent, and that seeks only nourishment
from its new host.
The outlines of that process sound pretty
similar to how early philosophers and scientists
envisioned their sperm-centric ideas of sexual
reproduction.
But what those scientists missed—
what separates the sperm from the zoospore—
is the nature of sexual reproduction itself,
of the genetic variation it drives by combining
and recombining traits from different parents.
Sperm cannot accomplish that on their own.
Sperm needs an ovum to fertilize, which scientists
would eventually uncover in the 19th century
with experiments on rabbits, sea urchins,
and starfish eggs that helped to further our
understanding of the molecular and cellular
collaboration that set the stage for inheritance.
Yes, my friends, as Napoleon drove to conquer
Europe, we had no idea that sperm and eggs
came together to make the next generation.
There are a lot of different
types of spores out there,
used for both sexual and asexual reproduction.
And in contrast, sperm might seem more narrow
and focused, both in diversity and purpose.
But the function of sperm is so specialized
that it requires its own diversity.
Even among tardigrades, there are different
morphologies to the head and middle structures
of the sperm, small differences that distinguish
between species.
And that’s because however weird our theories
about sperm have been, the reality is also
very strange.
Of all the cells in the body, sperm cells
are maybe the only ones that are expected
to navigate and survive in two different beings.
The homunculus was wrong, but the idea of
there being an image of our life passed on
within sperm and in spores, it isn’t absurd
at all.
It’s just too literal.
Instead, that image is abstracted and tucked
away into genetic information.
And zoospores and sperm alike are just packets
of that information, swimming off to new and
different futures.
So far we’ve seen the eggs, the sperm, and
the very messy process of getting the two to meet.
And for our last video, we want to focus on
what all this is meant to be for:
baby tardigrades!
We’ll also find out the fate of our pregnant
water bear from the first episode, and see
what lessons we learned in the process.
Hello, everyone, and welcome back to the second
half of our tardigrade reproduction spectacular.
In our last episode, we got a very close look,
though I suppose all of our looks are pretty
close, at the various biological intimacies
exchanged by tardigrades as they mate.
Multiple males contended for the heart, or
at least the unfertilized eggs, of a female
tardigrade by poking endlessly at her exuvia.
It was really quite dramatic, and if you haven't
watched it yet, you should.
It’s great.
There’s poop.
But now, it is time for the thrilling conclusion
to all of that mating: the babies.
This tardigrade has been lugging her future
offspring in a sack made up of her exuvia,
which is her shedded exoskeleton.
Like a spare room that's been converted into
a baby nursery, the same exuvia that started
as the mother's own cuticle before it became
the site of courtship, has now undergone another
renovation to become a handy, portable egg
nursery.
The ways that tardigrades deal with their
eggs may look different for different species.
While this water bear carries her exuvia at
the end of her body, some species carry it
more towards the front.
Some don't lay eggs in exuvia at all, while
another species has been seen depositing their
eggs in the exuvia of water fleas.
Why our species has evolved or chosen this
method is unknown to us.
Maybe it allows her to provide them protection,
or perhaps she can ensure they hatch in the
best possible location this way.
We just don't know.
But we did very much want to observe this
mother-to-be.
And so for three days, we followed her, doing
our best to also take good care of her.
Now, the biggest concern was making sure she
wouldn't get too dry, so we had to keep her
away from the edges of the slide.
To do this we used only the most advanced
techniques: we poked her with the fine hair
from a brush to push her towards the more
watery regions of the slide.
We even set an alarm to remind us to add a
drop of water to the slide every four hours.
Yes, even at night.
That’s a lot of alarms.
Now, you might be thinking--aren't tardigrades
supposed to be the hardiest creatures on Earth?
Able to withstand extreme conditions, hypothetical
apocalypses, and maybe even crash landings
on the moon?
Surely they do not require this level of helicopter
parenting (or I guess it’s grandparenting?).
Well, we do care a lot for all of our microscopic
organisms, and so it could be that this watery
vigil is just an abundance of caution on our
part.
But we've seen with our own eyes that no matter
how tough tardigrades may be, the microcosmos
is tougher.
Sometimes things just...happen, and not in
the way you might hope.
You might remember this tardigrade from a
previous episode.
We were pretty excited about her because we
could see all of those eggs just ready to
be hatched.
But the mother was completely still.
She hadn't moved at all, which would usually
be worrisome.
But she wasn't decomposing, so we thought
maybe she was still alive, just biding the
time until her eggs hatched.
And so while she waited, so did we.
Gestation in tardigrades can vary quite a
bit, not just by species, but with temperature
and just plain old chance.
It generally takes a few days, but it can
take months.
We kept her in a humidity chamber and checked
in to make sure the coverslip wasn't crushing her.
But the inactive tardigrade never became active
again.
Eventually, her body did begin to decompose,
as did the eggs inside her.
And so, this tardigrade family was not meant
to be.
We don't know what killed this tardigrade,
but it's hard not to feel responsible for
the organisms we film.
Sure, they're unaware of our existence,
but they are in our care, and like the animals
and humans we come to feel connected to, it's
sad to be reminded that endings can come for
even the mightiest creatures among us, even
if they're also among the smallest.
That's why, when we later found the impending
tardigrade mother that started this episode,
we took so much care to keep her alive.
It was nerve-wracking because we didn't want
to lose another brood, hence the 4 hour alarms
and the brush hair.
So you might be able to imagine our combined
excitement and relief when after 4 days of
this intensive care, we saw a tardigrade cuticle
that was no longer full of eggs--it was full
of egg shells and baby tardigrades!
Now unfortunately, it turned out that getting
footage of the actual hatching during this
moment was challenging.
The eggs would roll around in the cuticle
while also being dragged by the mother.
But you can see the baby tardigrades clawing
their way through the mass of eggs.
Eventually though, the mother finally completely
shed her cuticle.
You can see it here, it almost looks like
a tardigrade ghost chasing behind her.
This moment was particularly fortuitous for
us because as the tardigrade rid herself of
the exuvia that had housed her future children,
one unhatched egg came out as well.
It's weird to look at this and realize that
in a few moments, out will come a tardigrade.
Just an oval with some lines in it, a formed
thing packed away.
That arrow-shaped thing that's pumping away
is the tardigrade's stylets, a part of their
mouth that pokes out when it comes time to
eat and it helps the tardigrade suction out
the meatiness of the microbes that it feeds
on.
But before they can get to eating, the stylets
have an important task: helping the baby tardigrade
get out of their shell.
After two hours of struggling, the stylets
of the tardigrade begin to move more repetitively
until finally, it's able to poke holes in
the egg.
These holes allow water into the egg, increasing
the pressure inside until the egg just pops
and out comes a little moss piglet.
And with it, a new generation is born, adding
to a lineage of mighty microscopic animals
stretching back hundreds of millions of years.
*sigh*
If you heard a sigh just then, it's a sigh of relief
and joy from all of us at the Microcosmos team.
When we set out to track and record a tardigrade
birth, we didn't know that it would lead to
both heartbreak and excitement.
But it's all worth it for this little buddy
among many.
We hope to see them all again, perhaps creating
their own brood.
But for now, paddle away, our little friend,
the whole microcosmos awaits.
Thank you for coming on this journey with us as
we explore the unseen world that surrounds us.
Big shout out to the people on the screen
right now.
They are our Patreon patrons.
They’re folks who think that there should
be a YouTube channel that, in a calm and serene
way, discusses the beautiful splendor of the
mystery of all the tiny things that are all
around us all the time, that for the vast
majority of human history, we had no idea
were even there.
So if you're happy that a channel like ours
exists, it's people like these who make that possible.
If you want to see more from our master of
microscopes, James Weiss, you can check out
Jam and Germs on Instagram.
And if you want to see more from us, there's
always a subscribe button somewhere nearby.